they certainly will recover them and
they exist since two thousand years and
they have a very strong message but they
don't deserve to recover soon unless
they really accept the guilt that some
individuals loaded on themselves and the
institution has to learn that perhaps
the conditions under which priests work
are conducive to certain misbehavior so
maybe the conditions will have to be
changed this has been the case in the
so-called Reformation by Martin Luther
and others at that time the Catholic
Church was in a much worse state of
affairs much with much more guilt in
that sense than today and it has kind of
led to a purification the challenge from
the reformate from the Reformation has
led the Catholics to learn much from
Luther and others so now they are almost
indistinguishable
you